hey guys my name is heinrich drake am
thurn doing coffee break learning europe
all have a good time to day i'm talking
about how you can actually bring skills
to door and play to the workplace even
as new business trainer level for just
the start of  university of the season
rente dollar wird ruf ist mit you
started newplacement working with the
company is using the attack jack white
sometimes until you up to speed in jubel
user beard bildband compared to be a
professional back in the fourth single
all the way you make up  from university
value learns lots of theoretical
knowledge with the bees of working and
funds around the cockpit law getting things
done know how things are actually then
in practice with take you but sometimes
we used to learn atelier had level a
few with professional senio field and of
course  it business practical des very
similar to certain software architecture
quite some time to catch up in really to
the place of the process tour level
w  ird all the people in the organization
documented ready for use the sphinx
beering set for my experience after many
using consulting a popular one of the
technical skills that you can learn to
quickly as usual for do you really had a
specific areas significant advantage
compared to the people working
organizing the east technical skills
on first point against good powerpoint
and excel good microsoft excel
so let's talk about this to make it
through life
in what can you actually i do to build
these skills in the true fruits
last powerpoint will reputation is great job
operations  also the smi
small medium sized enterprises ewz power
point without databases in almost all of
their business functions and of course
and one hell of a time it is before internal
presentations for internal communication
with the and the other side from so for
communication with external stakeholders
leica stores so other investors their
stakeholders because they can imagine
especially fo  r the slammed type of
presentations the super talent prima jays
in the high interest of the sea level
executives in your company proved
presentations an getting then the
professional level editor for metadata
of something in pfrondorf investor in
front of banks he wants to make things i
percentage not  only in the turn of the
contender deeply shying away from cars is
a formula prince on the presentation
is professional it can be sure to
anything you waiting to sales
presentation immediately to customers but
fink would have all stakeholders in the nabu
the bed in the cooperation of my
experience  herrenwörth with manny germany
corporation spec operations for europe
in the outside but continent very very few
people in the organizations of the
bluechip company have the skill
powerpoint presentation synovate israeli
military says that many people have some
basic skills can create sams la die
slides an orte level you  expect the myth
and you work in the lodge consulting for
like mc  kinsey bcg or this release
kills the value of the skills development
torwart.de for you can bring this
powerpoint skills to the table of you
can get to level at you better in
creating powerpoint pages because
according to people he had to be in the organization
that can be used for  you up to the point
the c or c level executives of your
company went to work gallery the winners
only because you can help them to get
this presentation tool levels willi
making of difference before this people and
if you old point of exposure to the
most important most  senior project of the
york city players working on a direct
exposure to dc level executive suite
people need you use and use until the
end ismaik possible in the likes
of experience for what have experienced
each not dead difficult to get their 18
junior colleges learn the skills  of time
and sword afterbuy the scene people den
organizations so what can you actually
you in order to improve your skills and
power point of course on  e point is
always learning by doing the more
presentation of judo at the youth
theater prize of the choir from the
theory together kaindorf guidance you
need to know how presentations and
above all siena investor siena customer
support levels house presentation sex
we need to look like tasted  how nobody
walkways will coaching will in consulting
the jazz connoisseurs get there because you
don't know horny skin type at the
expense of china's kaba people who have done that
you can look at presents for get
some of the mill in your company by you
see how  this from the post look like what
were you can bring it in channel at the
palace flew in the prime videos link
5 if we may a talking about
the skillz a criticism mold on
myvideo.de
in order to get the presentation at
level so much free  solo this
video center for the series in
developing the skillz traded funds from
online course based on experience working
for over set mckinsey and how to cre  ate
sea level 3 presentations the so links
course in the video description below
thursday my word for the sexy
politblog interviews and many other
people storage and the free
support course so much check out the
description organization of the microsoft
excel powerpoint organization also of the
fine motor skills tableau software global
software so much impact organizations
just play off with the experience the
working group of companies many many
people like basic skills up on course
the pens along the department of work
and management accounting for work and
controlling department now the people
you see me be the one that  on average
people do not have the skills and yes we
can do some basic fringes der im juli not
be able to biltmore complex models to
biltmore complex dashboards that may be
help desk system consulting people do
kwai dorf in essen consulting to go into
cooperation or concerts  tasks us
for the freezers and figure couple of
model should capel  lo change of sport
at product ii should client to rehab in
because they work industry afford that
is just so crazy that they do not get
in excel model world you can just update
delicious lima automatically at the audi
superman july picture reporter
reports it is like that when you in  the 2 that is
edward happens in lucina that is and
unity for you because you can be the one
for your the partner business model the
action release itself divides the costa
favolosa kollegs down goalie juli
comes as if the way you are
you when you think  you can't really made
of this is important to really in car
which would you that again how can you
actually develops kills from this
experience is more power point to
learning by doing to try to fail
problems in excel you get stuck on over
time machine for  you doing the videos on
the content on excel and have no jude
sex and very practical picture there model
for wilfried you are further discounter
interest you where the videos of you  'd be
interested ossi and the channel let me
know just the few comments
lausanne fingerboard merkel these videos at the
ubigrate four goals
you can you would like to see more bond
des type of stuff that very much
appreciate your feedback help capello
guardia civil the pictures  in the hotel cube
the world object is so susan rice
developing new skills in powerpoint
excel from my experience is skills
relevant pretty much every industry
work on and pretty much every function
comes across a popular university
you get to know and soft skills skills
in powerpoint excel hair of  vas value
for use
so from ever you have opportunity to
work with the things to develop skills
ein kabel studidoo.de interested auto
das with theo lauber in order to improve
the skills at the gates and powerpoint
skills and working poor s top management
consultants where do  check out the
description tumor interview said if
you watch the video please press like
button in the hallway lear  n more about
things you can do to improve your career
and early button to stay up to date auto
content channel sales of watching this
is heinrich von berning